[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
et nous continuons à explorer les sujets
qui font débat en ce moment dans la
crise que traverse notre pays
avec aujourd'hui à des détonateurs
peut-être de ce mouvement des gilets
jaunes la limitation de vitesse à 80
kilomètres heure qui avait déjà provoqué
des manifestations avant la crise elle
même une mesure dont le premier ministre
cette semaine a annoncé l'efficacité
tout en admettant qu'elle pouvait être
discutée dans le cadre du débat actuel
pour en débattre ce matin avec nous de
nippes et si bonjour bonjour vous êtes
membre de la fédération française des
motards en colère très opposées depuis
le début à cette mesure
yves lemaire bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le directeur de la prévention routière
pour la grande région bourgogne franche
comté et françois xavier dugourd bonjour
bonjour vice-président à l'ère du
conseil départemental de côte-d'or on
sait que certains conseils
départementaux comme la côte-d'or
demandent à pouvoir déroger à cette
mesure
et avant de nous pencher précisément sur
la mesure elle même sur son efficacité
sur son avenir
on est obligé de prendre en compte le
contexte actuel les manifestations
contre cette mesure ont débuté avant la
crise des gilets jaunes proprement dite
il ya eu la destruction pendant la crise
de près de 60% des radars est ce que
cette mesure était une mesure de plus
depuis les premières limitations on va
le rappeler de 73 est ce que cette
mesure est devenue un élément de cette
crise nationale françois xavier dugourd
c'est certain que quand on observe la
crise on voit bien que la voiture est là
au coeur des problèmes on le voit pas ce
que le détonateur effectivement il ya eu
les 80 km/heure bay a eu aussi la taxe
sur les carburants
on voit que la crise et se manifeste
aussi comment par les radars qui sont
tagués ou détruits
elle se manifeste par les des
manifestations sur les ronds points
on voit bien que la voiture elle est au
coeur de la problématique une des
premiers meetic pourquoi parce que cette
mesure des 80 km heure comme la taxe sur
les carburants
elle touche largement le milieu rural où
les périphéries la france périphérique
et d'ailleurs il ya une étude dans le
figaro je sais pas si elle a vu chi chi
deux pages qui étudie précisément la
composition sociologique
ddd gilet jaune et on le voit bien une
partie importante sont des gens qui sont
éloignés des bills plus ils sont
éloignés de plus une forte participation
ça veut dire qu'ils ont ce sont des
personnes qui ont besoin de leur voiture
pour leurs déplacements pour leur vie
quotidienne pour leur travail pour le
revoici ça me fait rebondir sur votre
voisin ce que ça veut dire que les gens
qui s'opposent aux 80 denis petit s'est
aussi déjà les jo alors fatalement oui
un petit peu même si la fédération
française des motards en colère ne
soutient pas directement les gilet jaune
puisque nous on a aussi d'autres
d'autres combats que le social dans son
dans son général sur la limitation de
vitesse et des 80 km/heure bourgeois
largement la position des jeunes et
jolies effectivement et du coup le maire
c'est très compliqué de parler de cette
mesure dans la crise actuelle
ça devient un symbole et c'est très
compliqué déjà j'ai un rôle difficile
parce que on vous a mis tout seul
effectivement je ne suis pas le
représentant de l'état l'association
prévention routière fait partie de la
sécurité routière mais totalement
indépendante donc je n'engage que mon
association quand je parle pour moi je
dis que sur cette affaire il faut raison
garder faut raison garder parce que
toute façon c'est un sujet qui est
passionnel je dirais quoi qu'il arrive
je suis convaincu vous êtes convaincus
et nous repartirons avec nos opinions
nous n'arrivons pas à nous contacter à
d'irlande
voilà moi ce que je veux dire simplement
c'est que la vitesse la conséquence de
la vitesse c'est qu'elle agit direct
quand on baisse la vitesse on baisse le
nombre d'accidents on baisse la gravité
des accidents
deuxièmement s'il joue si vous me
permettez cette présentation je vous
dire en quatre points simplement quatre
choses qui résistent qui répliquent
agression pas ma question qui résiste à
toutes les opinions vous dire que nous
sommes en europe en 12e position tout ce
qui est du ratio morts sur la route
population dans la mauvaise moyenne dans
les dix premiers les cinq pays qui ont
de petites 80 km/heure dont l'espagne
qui va aussi maintenant bientôt adopter
des 80 km heure
quand on roule à ça quand on roule à 80
km/heure on quand on roule à 90 km/heure
on gagne une seconde ou km je reviens
sur les gens qui sont à l'origine de ce
mouvement qu'on appelle par ailleurs
aussi là la france des lotissements le
déplacement moyen est de 20 km 20 km que
multiplie cinq secondes 140 combat sur
une minute trente deux trois 3 minutes
par parrot déplacements pendulaires
si vous me permettez juste quand même
pour qu'on reste dans ce qu'on voulait
demandant ce qu'on évoquait depuis le
début est ce que vous comprenez ce qui
est évoqué par les gens par exemple du
monde rural qui disent mais du coup on
se traîne et personne n'a réfléchi que
nous on doit faire 30 km par jour avec
notre voiture mais on ne se trompe pas
puisque je ne vous dira que l'on met 5
secondes par kilomètre
comme je disais souvent souvent la
vitesse avait plus ressenti que réelle
et bien c'est pareil le temps il est
plus ressenti que réelle le temps écoulé
plus ressenti que rennes
non je ne suis absolument pas d'accord
avec le propos de monsieur le maire le
la durée de trajet n'est pas
effectivement la chose la plus grave et
la plus importante dans ce sujet le fait
est que maintenant au même rythme que
les camions notamment
et quand on se retrouve avec plusieurs
véhicules laissez-moi terminé s'il
allait lorsque on se retrouve avec de
nombreux véhicules acquis à coller les
uns derrière les autres
il arrive parfois que certaines
personnes craquent un petit peu se
mettent à doubler dans n'importe quelle
circonstance et qu'on se retrouve avec
des comportements dangereux lié
uniquement à cette limitation à 80 km à
l'est c'est déjà le cas actuellement
c'était déjà le code que avec 90 km
heure on s'est dit qu'à l'obligation de
circuler à 80 km heure pour les poids
lourds elle date de 1984 mais
mathématiquement quant à quoi l'on roule
à 80 km/heure si vous roule à 90 vous
pouvez pas de doublé déjà vous étiez en
infraction pour le doublé tout
simplement
alors moi j'ai envie de pour avancer
deux de se référer aux chiffres en tout
cas les chiffres le premier ministre a a
évoqué lundi ce qui a surpris un certain
nombre de gens certains pensaient
d'ailleurs qu'on allait déjà revenir sur
la mesure où que ça allait être assoupli
le premier ministre a annoncé que 116
vies avaient été sauvées sur les routes
secondaires baissé à 80 km/heure moi
j'ai envie de vous dire tourner vers
ceux qui sont pas forcément d'accord
avec la mesure est ce qu'on peut encore
discuter après ce chiffre après 116 vie
vous savez les chiffres
on leur fait dire tout ce qu'on veut
vous avez cité certains pays européens
on peut en citer d'autres où la vitesse
est supérieure à 80 km/heure et où il ya
moins de morts qu'en france deuxièmement
la côte d'or on connaît bien la
côte-d'or nos conseillers départementaux
ou connaît bien notre terrain les
chiffres voilà les chiffres en côte-d'or
2018 la mesure a été appliquée à partir
du 1er juillet 2018 il y a eu quatre
morts sur les routes de côte-d'or au
premier semestre 2018
je suis deuxième semestre 2010 8 11
morts alors que on était à 80 km/heure
90 km/heure quatre morts 80 km/heure 11
morts ça veut dire que les chiffres on
peut les prendre dans tous les sens mais
le problème par des mails et chefs
rebelles depuis 1973 françois xavier
dugourd quand même c'est regarder arrivé
depuis 73 on baisse la vitesse depuis 73
ya moins de morts mais oui mais c'est la
région parce que tout le monde est prêt
de sécurité routière qui sont prises et
l'amélioration des routes
le problème de la sécurité routière
monsieur le maire le sait bien c'est
multifactoriel ya toute une série de
choses aujourd'hui on le sait bien les
gros problèmes de sécurité routière
étienne aux grands excès de vitesse les
grands excès de vitesse et ils tiennent
à l'alcool y tiennent aux stupéfiants
il ya toute une série à l'état des
routes il ya toute une série de maisons
baissent de la grèce lundi à calais
c'est le nombre de morts peut manier un
peu tombés d'accord là dessus quand même
alors les chiffres partout en europe
c'est vrai depuis quarante ans les
chiffres de la mortalité baisse fort
heureusement c'est une chose au tout le
monde peut se recueillir
maintenant il ya cette fois pourquoi
cette mesure là elle serait pas comme
les autres alors pourquoi je vais
d'abord faire terminer mon propos si
vous voulez bien il faut ne pas perdre
de vue que l'état des véhicules et la
conception des véhicules a énormément
augmenté dans les même période sur des
véhicules qu'elles auront d'aujourd'hui
ne sont pas sûrs et cliquer le rouleur
75 et que par ailleurs j'aimerais bien
qu'on m'explique comment il se fait que
l'endroit où il ya le moins de morts est
le moins d'accidents c'est l'endroit où
roulent le plus vite l'endroit le plus
sécurisé en france actuellement reste
l'autoroute et c'est bien limitée à
130km mais c'est parce que vous roulez
dans le même sens là on parle bien de
lait d'une limitation de vitesse sur les
routes bidirectionnelle sans aménagement
centrale là vous parlez de l'autoroute
les voitures roulent tous dans le même
sens forcément les insécurités mugard
entendre en fait j'ai envie de poser de
poser une question qui va peut-être vous
paraître naïve prenons problème à
l'envers pourquoi est-ce qu'un premier
ministre qui sait qu'une mesure est
aussi impopulaire s'obstinerait à la
maintenir s'il n'y avait pas aussi des
gens qui étaient absolument intimement
persuadé que ça marchait vas-y que
politique
est-ce que je vous donnais une raison
simple c'est parce qu'il est déconnecté
il est déconnecté la réalité du terrain
que c'est une mesure parisienne moon qui
a été prise centraliser technocratique
sans consultation du terrain des gens
qui connaissent le terrain qui est-ce
qui connaît le terrain
qui est-ce qui connaît le terrain c'est
qu'ils soient ces départemental on gère
5800 km de routes tout là-haut quotidien
on a des dizaines d'agents qui sont sur
le terrain ils connaissent parfaitement
les routes vous êtes un spécialiste de
l'accidentologie non mais je dis quand
même parce que ce n'est pas un peu de
pardon pardonnez moi de vous dire comme
ça parce qu'on n'est pas dans la tarte à
la crème c'est à dire si on s'occupe du
bitume des routes ça fait pas de vous
des spécialistes de l'accidentologie les
baies sûr qu'on est les spécialistes
c'est à dire est ce que vous savez que
en côte-d'or et monsieur le maire le
sait aussi
dès qu'il ya un accident qu'est-ce qui
se passe on a mis en place un collège de
sécurité routière ça vous ne voulez pas
du tout des ateliers y est là contraire
on veut plus de sécurité routière et
décrit un accident sur les routes de
côte-d'or qu'est-ce qui se passe il ya
un collège qui se réunit à l'initiative
du département qui associe la
gendarmerie je peux vous dire que la
gendarmerie ils connaissent bien
vous savez qu'ils ont été ils n'ont pas
du tout été associé à la mesure 1 les
gendarmes alors qu'eux ils connaissent
aussi des routes un collège qui a le
département les élus locaux les maires
qui connaissent leur territoire les
gendarmes les associations qu'ils soient
sociales qu est ce que la georges dit il
ya un accident sur la route
pourquoi d'où vient cet accident et
comment on peut améliorer
l'infrastructure c'est ça la sécurité
routière c'est du cas par cas
c'est d'être pragmatique en tenant
compte du territoire et c'est pas une
mesure prise de paris par des bobos
parisiens excusez moi qui roulent en
taisant airways ou alors en trottinette
électrique qui savent ce qu'il faut
faire
entre champlitte et dijon
le problème le maire mesures de bobos
parisiens qui roulent en trottinette et
les normands parce que je réfute cet
argument parce que bon déjà simplement
un chiffre 1 quand on prend le ratio
population morts sur la route à paris c
17 en moyenne française 54 les
départements ruraux sens donc c'est bien
fait c'est bien dans les départements
ruraux qu'il faut agir
je vous rappelle que les axes bear head
bidirectionnelle ses 55 % des accidents
mortels ces 19 s'en mord encore les
dernières c'est bien sûr là où ça roule
le plus qui a des accidents monsieur à
moi je voudrais pas prolonger mon propos
si vous me le permettez notre population
vieillit les juges âgées vieillissent
vous avez en charge le vieillissement
dans le département et pour qui la
vitesse est la plus élevée et là vous
savez qu'on facteurs ont fêté ensemble
mais qu'il pour qu'il a d'abord pour les
personnes âgées c'est les plus fragiles
monsieur donc ça va beaucoup de ça
risque de vous coûter plus cher
je vois pas le rapport avec 80,2 ya deux
jours monsieur tendez le coût de la
sécurité routière 38 milliards d'euros
si on veut commencer à faire des
économies la faisons des économies sur
le coût de la sécurité routière et la
halle et la limitation de vitesse et
d'un état des meilleurs arguments
mais je le mets aux économies sur leur
coûte l'insécurité bonne idée mais non
excusez monde et la sécurité
alors vous allez insécurité à la
sécurité routière parce que vous avez
fait peur que vous avez dit la seven a
mis sur la sécurité routière vous m'avez
vraiment fait peur mais est ce que
j'avais envie de vous entendre aussi sur
ce qu'évoquait françois xavier dugourd
si on se dit il ya eu des mesures de
sécurité routière depuis on disait les
années 70 accor est ce que en quoi celle
ci est lé plus déconnectés du terrain
puisque vous avez dit bobo parisien avec
trottinette et fallou pour voir sortir
ça vous apparaît comme ça aussi tout à
fait différente des autres mesures celle
là je pense qu'il ya seulement aucune
concertation c'est vraiment une décision
parisienne c'est du parisianisme
complètement dissociés demandé la
circulation routière en général c'est
l'état central c'est pas un pouvoir en
france
c'est ce que les hélicos six
départements les conseils départementaux
demandent d'avoir aussi la libre le
libre choix et le
quel jugement sur christophe c est ce
que ça serait pas me dit est ce que ce
serait pas pire qu'un département décide
de baisser lot de monter une rose à gaza
il ou non mais qu'est ce qui fait la
force
qu'est ce qui fait la force d'une
limitation de vitesse c'est sa
lisibilité c'est son mono homogénéité
comment les gens vont faire je passe de
la côte d'or à la nièvre ça change le
rythme change
qu'est-ce qui marquait ce qui nous
garantit monsieur qu en cas d'alternance
politique les gens qui voudraient vous
succédez ont changé ce que vous avez
décidé mais c'est pas une mesure
politique monsieur le maire s'est engagé
le signe et le signataire le signataire
est quand même bien responsabilité mais
ce qu'on a ce qu'on demande nous le
céder dès que les élus locaux que les
acteurs de terrain soient associés s'est
mesuré à l'ennemi tu ne voulais pas du
tout contre les la baisse de la vitesse
dans certains secteurs et aller vite on
leur a tout à fait prêts sur certains
secteurs a baissé
attendez qu'on puisse baisser la vitesse
à 50 km heure à 30 km/heure donc
certains espaces on n'est pas des
ayatollahs de la vitesse ce que nous
reprochons c'est une mesure uniforme
prise sans concertation avec ceux qui
travaillent qui compte connaissent ces
routes
c'est ça notre problème elle et
indifférenciée ya certaines routes du
département qui peut-être mérite qu'on
baisse à 70 60 parce que l son risque
elles sont accidentogènes a en revanche
laissé 90 km heure
monsieur le maire est-ce que vous avez
repris depuis que la mesure est prise
c'est ce que vous avez pris la rd 974
entre dijon et beaune est gelée vous en
parler à des gens bien je les besoins
dans les 39 km 42 longueurs différentes
mais choqué pour ceux qui ne l'ont pas
vu les bourguignons qui n'ont pas vu
c'est une route sur lequel il ya eu 40
sur un an de virelles à 40 de changement
de vitesse j'avais envie de vous poser
une question parce que qu'elle est bien
quelque chose qu'on n'a pas dit denis b
si vous êtes représenter la fédération
française des motards en colère
donc vous êtes motards oui et est ce que
cette mesure elle gêne plus elle
concerne plus les motards que les
voitures
est ce que c'est juste parce que les
motards aime bien rouler vite parce
qu'ils ont des motos qui roulent mais où
est ce que l gêne plus les motards la
vitesse de la moto c'est un autre sujet
serpent débattre très longuement non
nous ce qu'on reproche c'est que ça
touche absolument tous les usagers de la
route c'est pas une histoire d'être en
vie
voitures motos ou dans un camion et un
but ça touche tous les usagers et c'est
vraiment des choses qui sont
impressionnantes nous ce qu'on réclame
le plus haut niveau de la pour la
sécurité routière au niveau de la
fédération française des motards en
colère c'est qu'on améliore les
infrastructures que les routes soient
mises en meilleur état et il y aura la
mutation de vitesse est liée à rossi
assad en place et les conseils
départementaux et c'est pour ça que je
travaille à ce que qu'on travaille quand
on se réunit dans les fameux collège
je félicite conseil départemental de les
avoir maintenus parce qu'il n'existe
plus dans tous les départements
c'est ça ça existait précédemment
c'était une mesure nationale et ça a été
maintenu dans le département de la côte
d'or
cet appartement en faisant mes contacts
donc je sais ce que je veux dire est ce
que je veux dire c'est que l'état de la
route des équipements de la route ne
sont jamais la cause majeure des
accidents il ya toujours une question
90% des accidents monsieur résultent de
comportements
moi je suis un ancien taulier pas de vie
quand vous arrivez sur l'année sur un
accident
qu'est ce qu'on entend j'ai pas vu j'ai
pas su faire j'ai pas compris on est
dans sa voiture on est incapable de
prendre une existence l'existence de
l'autre quand on est haut quand on est
au volant
la première chose c'est de se dire je
roule avec des autres et en permanence
ce doit être à même d'anticiper sur
leurs éventuelles fautes et c'est pour
ça que tous les accidents de tous les
accidents dans toutes les études que
nous faisons le sud du bourg ça met en
exergue quoi le comportement des gens
monsieur le maire dans ce comportement
on est bien d'accord et fois que le
comportement à l'école et la vitesse et
l'alcool la vitesse et l encadrement
d'accord l'alcool les stupéfiants
on est d'accord monsieur le maire oui
mais les stupéfiants commencé que vers
lecco à 6,80 à l'heure il sera aussi
dangereux à 80 alors que 90 une question
justement sur cette vitesse à partir
d'un point d'actualité là on l'a appris
ce matin cette nuit en saône et loire
épinac en saône et loire cinq jeunes ont
été blessés dont un grièvement dans une
fiction une sortie de route
est-ce qu est-ce que ce qui se passe les
80 km heure yves lemaire ça change
quelque chose pour ce litige
inévitablement isolé ou s'il respecte
les limitations de vitesse
quand on roule moins vite on tap - fois
on s'arrête à bromont donc les
conséquences auraient été moins grave
alors j'aurais failli à priori rade
morts
liberté comme ça tenait un de se passer
j'en ai profité que c'est sur la rc va
parce que vous connaissez la rca cayla
psenak donc non bon mais parce que la
rca c'est la route la plus mortifères de
france beaucoup
non mais c'est une illustration sur
l'état à mon sens avant de s'occuper des
80 kilomètres heure qui met qu'il faut
c'est un investissement considérable sur
cette route qui guérit mais comme et
avec combien d'années de retard monsieur
et tous les gouvernements d'ailleurs il
yad'autres gillet qui sont là voyez la
judée rouge couleur la rcea de mettre
financement lors les moissons
l'environnement avant qu'on passe à ce
qui va se passer moi je voulais juste
revenir sur le problème de comportement
qu'évoquer monsieur le maire nous à la
fédération française des motards en
colère
on est totalement pour une modification
des comportements c'est pour ça que l'on
travaille dès le lycée dès le collège
avec notre éducation routière à la
jeunesse on a des intervenants qui sont
formés qui sont agréés par l'éducation
nationale qui interviennent dans les
collèges al ensuite on a le ont fait ce
qu'on appelle la fdm la formation des
conducteurs qui fait que tous les ans on
propose des stages nos adhérents pour
repartir et toujours avoir une petite
remise en cause alors je reviens je
reviens sur je reviens sur
l'environnement pardon juste pour pour
terminer ce chapitre là parce que faut
quand même on sait que dans cette mesure
il ya quand même l'idée de réduire les
émissions de polluants de réduire les
consommations de carburant 10 km heure c
c'est quand même réelles estimées à
sonate à 120 euros par voilà c'était 120
euros et est-ce qu'on n'est pas là
encore comme pour l'augmentation du prix
des carburants françois xavier dugourd
dans le fait que personne ne se
préoccupe réellement d'environnement
parce que finalement ça a complètement
disparu du site
c'est quand on parle de 80 kilomètres
heure personne n'en parle de ça oui je
pense vous savez sur ce sujet là je
pense que la réponse est pas forcément
évidente parce que et une circulation
fluide
à mon avis elle est beaucoup moins
polluante que certains bouchons qui
peuvent apparaître quand il ya des
camions à 80 km/heure qu'on n'arrive pas
à doubler et des files de voitures qui
semble regarder la vie nos donc vous
comptez alors ça veut donc dire que vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec les chiffres de
la moi je pense qu on peut pas encore
raisonner de manière homogène ces
territoires route par route qu'il faut
barbares comme ça fait beaucoup
d'experts qui se trompent pas parce que
l'ademe les autres chiffres sur le recul
parce que je vous rappelle
on oublie une chose c'est que cette
mesure on s'était donné un délai de deux
ans pour l'expertisé pour l'évaluer
normalement il faut cinq ans pour avoir
une évaluation juste
je rappelle que les experts parisiens
c'est quand même le serema le serena est
présent dans chaque région ne sont pas
que des études régionales qui sont
communiquées à paris bien sûr qu'ils
sont analysés atari ce qu'ils
travaillaient de serge fiori s qui
travaille avec elle et les élus locaux
et bien sûr puisqu'ils sont ils sont
destinataires du jamais vu ils sont
destinataires de lait des bulletins
d'accidents qui sont rédigées par les
forces de police et gendarmerie
c'est des données qui sont objectives et
objective et c'est des gens qui
travaillent 1 le sert et moi je rappelle
ce centre d'études 1 pour le prévention
du risque des mobilités et des
aménagements 1 c'est des gens sérieux
bon alors que va devenir cette mesure
maintenant est ce que c'est la question
certains attendaient dès lundi un retour
en arrière on en avait parlé premier
nice n'a pas cédé lui il a l'air de pas
vouloir céder
ça reste ambigu parce qu'il a en même
temps admis qu'il était légitime de
discuter mais qu'il serait fou de
baisser le niveau de beast d'ambition
quand on a dit ça en fait on sait pas du
tout ce qu'on va faire un vide c'est
faire et ne pas faire tout en faisant si
on revient dessus livre le maire ce
serait un symbole ce serait la première
fois qu'on viendrait sur une limitation
de vitesse en france on est bien
d'accord même eu pire puisque le
président a parlé de revoir les choses
avec intelligence donc en partie au
moment de se passer nous prenons
simplement c'est sûr que les gens autant
là on attaque la reine la raison d'être
de cette cette limitation de vitesse
dans son efficacité dans sa périnée ça
veut dire que c'est toute l'idée de la
limitation de vitesse qui est mise en
cause
oui alors que je vous dis tout concours
tout concourt au contraire moi ce que je
vous dire simplement c'est que on l'a vu
je le disait dernièrement à chaque fois
que les le politique s'occupe de
sécurité routière ça va à l'encontre de
ce que près de ce que de ce que les
textes ont pu préconisé rapidement le
délai d'un an le délai de deux ans entre
deux stages de récupération de points
baisser un an
c'est une mesure qui socialement permet
à certaines personnes de faire des
stages plus fréquemment que les autres
ce qui prend une bonne chose et surtout
d'entretenir des gens dans leurs
mauvaises habitudes sur la route moi ce
que je veux dire simplement un c'est
qu'en la matière j'irai droit au but
populisme et sécurité routière ne m'ont
pas de père françois-xavier dugourd on
sait que françois sauvadet a pris un peu
la tête de la wii une sorte de front
en dix ans nous il faut qu'ils conseils
départementaux puis on va dire déroger
enfin choisir eux mêmes c'est la
solution c'est vous seriez vous
changeriez combien de % imaginons
imaginons louis que quand vous donne
cette possibilité
ça fait quel pourcentage des routes de
côte-d'or qui était à 81 qui remet à
remontrer à 90 un tout petit pois déjà
le conseil départemental heures décembre
2017 a alerté sur cette mesure et
françois sauvadet dans la foulée a dit
au gouvernement
si vous prenez cette mesure ce sera
votre boulet il a dit au premier
ministre sa date de début 2018 et voyez
aujourd'hui les gilet jaune
enfin bref nous on est prêt à être
encore une fois on veut pas plus de
vitesse sur les routes
on n'est pas contre la sécurité routière
évidemment enfin monsieur le maire le
sait bien on travaille au quotidien
nous ce que nous voulons c'est un
travail au cas par cas
pragmatique sur les territoires sur les
secteurs avec les élus locaux avec la
gendarmerie avec la sécurité ça veut
donc dire que des routes que vous
laisserez à 80 kilomètres peut-être que
vous avez seriez oui oui peut-être
si si on juge effectivement que c'est
nécessaire pourrait limiter les
accidents oui donc en pourcent partiel
5800 qu'il ma question c'est plus de la
moitié moins de la moitié est ce que est
ce que dans ce cas là ce serait beaucoup
qu'ils reviendraient à quatre mois et
c'est ça le difficile encore une fois le
problème de cette mesure uniforme prises
à paris par des technocrates non
sincèrement sans lien avec le territoire
ceux qui connaissent le territoire ce
sont les c'est vous monsieur le maire
n'est passé à voir donc pardon excusez
moi mais quand on est passé à 90 km
quand on a pris des mesures
c'était déjà une mesures nationales
prises par des spécialistes de sécurité
routière et quand on a baissé quand on a
baissé la ligne 5 les conseils
départementaux juste n'avait pas le la
gestion des routes exactement où ils
étaient beaucoup moins s'impliquer ou
vous demander votre avis on connaissait
beaucoup moins aussi le vide l'expertisé
développée sur les territoires le
travail je me parlait des collèges de
sécurité routière aujourd'hui on connaît
extrêmement bien les lieux
accidentogènes et c'est donc ça a changé
la politique change et l'action publique
j'essayais le premier ministre a admis
que et d'ailleurs c'est prévu cette
mesure elle est en discussion dans le
grand débat actuellement le traitement
des kilomètres heure est-ce que
une organisation comme la vôtre elle va
dans les débats elle pèse et l'essai de
d'agir là dessus alors on la fédération
française des motards en colère est
invité entre guillemets invité aux cds
ère où effectivement et mais le problème
c'est que ces desserts conseil
départemental
donc si on est certain de conseil
national de sécurité routière
non mais moi je pensais aux grands
débats ce qui se passe en ce moment dans
toutes les villes on organise des débats
sur toutes les questions que vous savez
le tour de la crise si on me le
permettez je me bats tomber dans le mais
après il ordonnerait dans le déballage
de nos actions mais nous on est dans le
grand débat permanent
l'année dernière on a fait plus de 4500
heures 4000 16h02 d'animation nous les
gens nous font remonter très grande
majorité on a compris qu'en réalité vous
parlez encore une très grande majorité
de les gens et pour la limitation de
vitesse à 80 km/heure nous le grand
débat en lan permanence rouler partout
je vous dis actuellement ce que l'on
sonné c'est la même réaction que l'on a
eues en 92 ou 93 lorsqu'il s'est agi de
baisser la limitation dans les villes de
60 à 50 km heure
quand vous touchez au quotidien des gens
automatiquement vous êtes forme de
radicalité de comportement qui
s'installe monsieur laberge les gens ces
boîtes sur leurs habitudes dans les
débats en milieu rural vous allez voir
vous allez entendre les gens qui
fabriquent du jour les gens qui sont
obligés de prendre leur voiture ils ne
font pas par plaisir il c'est une
obligation pour aller travailler pour
ramener leurs enfants pour ramener leurs
grands parents etc
ces gens là je peux dire que la voiture
j'ai envie vous au site édition est un
peu juste parce qu'il nous reste une
minute une minute démission mais c'est
important si on remet à 90 km/heure
imaginons et ya plus de morts ou qui a
des morts sur une route ça va vouloir
dire que les collectivités qui l'auront
décidé porteront enfin est ce que est ce
que vous y pensez mais c'est passé la
question ne porterez vous pas notre vie
des moines mais est ce que vous y pensez
mais nous on assure le maire on assume
déjà tous les jours quelques anciens un
accident sur les routes on l'assument en
assumons complètement et en galets
effectivement que les le départ éventuel
de responsabilité donc on va continuer
encore une fois on veut pas forcément le
retour à une mesure uniforme
on veut du travail au cas par cas donc
l'idée de déroger sur certaines routes
non mais je rejoins tout à fait monsieur
d'humour c'est à dire que
notre souhait serait de laisser le libre
arbitre à chaque département à charge
aux locales de décider si la route est
sécurisé à 80 ou 90 soit 70 on pressent
qui aurait une validation des préfets ce
qui veut dire que ça limitera
probablement les changements il serait
plutôt pas mal aussi mais ça serait déjà
pas contre que les préfets parce
qu'encore une fois y est ce que je vais
m'efforcer cumul est simple la
gendarmerie la police je voulais
simplement dire c'est que les 118 morts
en moins c'est déjà quand même 116-113
chiffre jamais connu jusqu alors il y en
a un autre qui s'ajoute au mécénat connu
on a connu un très mauvais le mode
dessin doit scellier mais n'a connu un
très mauvais mois de décembre avec 60
morts à cause les radars qui était donné
deux filles et je suis obligé de vous
arrêter parce que c'est la femme notre
départ on s'était dit avant que ça
passait très vite vous l'avez vu sa
passe très vite merci à tous les trois
d'être venus débattre sur ce sujet qui
va se poursuivre parce qu'on va voir
comment ça se passe et ce que les
conseils départementaux obtiennent un
peu un pouvoir là-dessus
merci à tous les trois bons dimanches au
revoir
[Musique]
ans